this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
we're talking about testosterone guys
and chingo's blood work back and things
that look sometimes the engine needs to
be taken into the shop and dials have to
be fixed
that's all sometimes used to cut back on
the tiger thick that's all this comes
down to you might be running you might
be running on a different kind of
gasoline we got to take the lead out of
the gasoline gotta stop taking that pay
to drink some water drink some water
once and at your age I took a lot of
water but I drink alcohol too that's the
problem yeah that nullifies all of it
right my buddy Jerry my buddy Jerry the
doctor looks it's like I eat greens but
I do math yeah yeah my buddy okay Jerry
the doctor goes you have spots on your
tongue Jerry goes oh and he goes now
that's what could be pre-cancerous so he
goes he goes so uh and he goes in my
friend's fat and drinks and eats all the
food all the time I get it he goes what
do you think I should do and the doctor
goes
practice some self-restraint for God's
sake that's what most of it is and then
he wasn't and his doctor goes you're no
longer my patient I can't work with you
yeah chin you uh you could do it with me
if you want it's me some gangster [__]
there's a I'll send it to you there's
this football player
so this football player let me send to
Chin you'll you'll love this
um B there's this football player who um
great football player I think he's uh
he's at least some Pro balls with a
first round draft pick he's like
whatever 360 pounds and then retires and
he had all these issues with his body he
goes you know what that's him right
there he's been fasting for 40 days just
drinking water for 40 days oh my God
he's lost how much weight I think he's
190 pounds now what and he was 3 30.
hold on hold on 100 pounds by fasting in
40 days so Russell isn't that what Jesus
did fasted for 40 days yeah that was
something like that I wanted he's 34
years old he's locked over 100 pounds in
40 days the journey began at 330 pounds
300 more than 330 pounds now he's 2 30.
no he's 190 now this is that was older
he posted I follow him he posted he's
190 pounds now he he did nothing but
water just water
I fast for 40 days with water and he
goes uh yes you read that right the
experience was so rich and Warren I'm
gonna do it again
so so he has no so uh inquiring my
physical hunger I unlock mental Clarity
spiritual relevation total reset
um I was always told to eat big stay
strong and never questioned but breaking
away embracing fasting it changed
everything I'm not just slidering weight
I'm lighter and spirit
can I see that picture again of him
what the hell 330 pounds that's
obviously a very large man but isn't it
interesting without weights or you know
or just eating that much or body
goes down to that
3 30 and probably not doing the same
part like you're not I assume being on
that fasting diet you can't work out
like you did so you know you're not I
remember you tried to get down to like
220 or I got down to 224. that's really
hard for you though I mean I wasn't
fasting but the I see this stuff
obviously I've never fast for 40 days
yeah it's never going to happen I don't
want to do that to my body and there are
some dangers can you find out if Jesus
fasted for 40. I remember something like
that but that guy's real and did it
right so we want to focus on him or
Justin
it might be 40 nights and afterwards was
hungry the tempter approached him and
said you are the Son of God command that
these Stones become loaves of bread
that's right at the time Jesus led by
the spirit that's crazy man but this guy
actually just did it and there's he and
there's actually evidence he might have
done it because of the Bible dude well
sure there's good things that come out
of the Bible this guy actually didn't we
can prove it so that's cool well are you
saying hold on are you saying that I'm
just saying dudes
bro you are no I'm not some fast I need
some facts dude I remember this one oh
wow oh no I don't want to look like that
I don't want to look at that that's not
good maybe you should do it just to
reset your body chin do it for two days
I just started this morning I think I'm
gonna just quit the alcohol for a while
and then have good nutrition and then do
it after like you know I would go full
turkey on it cold turkey and that's what
you did did you fast too I would
intermittent fast basically until like
night time I would wake up I would drink
a little coffee drink water throughout
the day and then eat dinner yeah I know
I know a lot of successful people who
are pretty rip that do just one meal
they just eat at five they eat one big
meal at five and that's that's my
trainer does six caveman style same way
he looks good right amazing and I think
two part of my problem is I just get
bored I'm like nah what are we on the
cupboards and I'm eating [__] and
I'm like what am I doing I don't need
that I'm not even hungry no I'm just
bored you look good you look good yeah
but I I I like challenges like whenever
down like 40 can't do 40 days that's a
different level there's something going
on there yeah but then you know thank
God he did it and he's all right sounds
religious yeah probably I can't that's a
higher thing that I'm never gonna get to
40 days ain't for me I'm down to try for
a day let's do 24 hours see what happens
yeah you've done that before you have
done it before when I was trying to cut
that weight I was doing it when I
wrestled I would suck weight like that
it's different when you're a kid and
there's a reason we're a grown man
there's no reason it's tougher to stay
disciplined yeah when my kid's like Dad
I want Chick-fil-A I'm like I love
Chick-fil-A that's the thing and also
like at night sometimes I just really
want one beer I just want a beer I'm not
gonna drink anymore I'm like no don't
drink a whole beer I'll just have a sip
and it's like oh that's nice but I can't
daddy can't drink wine I can't do it
anymore you know I'm a wine guy yeah I
know but I love wine but I'll I'll do it
I'll go to it when I go to Vietnam like
I did last night and fabrita was like
hey bro let's open up this crazy bottle
I ain't saying no but I'm not sure yes
what's the point exactly that's the same
like some like I remember I was on diet
a while ago my kids were at like Disney
or Universal Studios and they're like oh
we're gonna eat them like ah there's
nothing Kenny I'm like what am I doing
what am I doing what am I doing why am I
doing this yeah I did I tell you my
recent Health scare
I tell you about it so I'm we're all
getting more healthier I mean as we get
older yeah I'm in [__] Israel
delivers the disaster my stomach is
super distended I'm like what the [__]
and then I have a I have this well I
have a tumor basically I'm like well I
have something on the side of my right
here under my rib that's obviously it's
like protruding well it's a tumor so I'm
like that's I'm definitely gonna die and
now I start getting psychosomatic pains
I'm like I have pains here and by the
way your liver is right there yeah I'm
like I have a growth on my liver yeah
you're also but what else could it be
you're also crazy what else could it be
I'm like that's clearly a tumor so I
call my doctor and I I actually FaceTime
I go dude I gotta I gotta show you this
and he goes what I go I have a some
tumor
and he goes where I go under my rib
there you go that's a rib I need a
sonogram and he goes like this he looks
there he goes why do you need a sonogram
for that well because I have a thing and
he goes yeah that's called a lipoma it's
like a fat thing fat build up yeah
adipose tissue build up yeah um he's
like hey I went in he goes he goes he
goes like this yep that's what that is
yeah I can open it what about he goes
nope that's what that is well me my girl
were you know a while ago because she
was like I have this lump on the back of
my neck it could be cancer I'm like let
me feel it's like a little not like it's
ingrown here it's ingrown here it's just
a fat buildup you know that's you know I
I hate the doctors it's like oh you
never go to the doctor she's like what
if it's cancer I'm like it's not a
guaranteed so she's uh and we're gonna
fight about him we call your doctor call
you go do all the thing and do it sure
enough oh yeah I was just a little fat
build up back there well it's like when
I had pain here and I wrote down hernia
and the doctor goes he takes my blood he
does this stuff he goes go down I go
down to the surgeon sir you know the
surgeons from Cedar cyanide they've seen
a couple of things yeah he comes in he's
got his things on with his stethoscope
they look like soldiers they've just
been through [__] any uh he looks the
thing and he goes you have a hernia
I go yeah he goes That's fascinating
I go why he goes
no just where is it I go like I hear no
wow he goes you'd be the first person in
history to have one there but yeah yeah
have you ever had a hernia she goes he
goes he goes like this he goes let me
guess why you really what you're really
doing here I said what he goes you want
to know if that's cancer yeah I'm going
to he goes it's not so get out of my
office dude if I do get cancer on me so
it's gonna be like stage five because I
refuse to go but that's why when my
girl's like there's a bum I'm like okay
it's nothing yeah that's how I am so
that's how you know I also might
whenever you hear people ah whenever you
hear people with cancer and they're like
how did you not know it's like a lot of
people are like me like [__] doctors man
you don't see the Gen the general doctor
but the general guy just the very Bland
like um
you know it yeah I would go see a
specialist I'm like why am I here then
yeah why am I talking to you if you
don't know what the [__] going on
that's right those general doctors my
doctor doesn't even listen to my heart
or look at my ears he's like I'll take
some blood tests you guys why don't he
goes you want to check your balls for
cancer I go nope he goes okay well
you're the whiny kid you know like
you're a doctor you come in he's like oh
God I never go you know what happens
you know you always FaceTime and
thinking no I really do when you do it I
guarantee the doctors goes let me talk
to this [__] real quick no the promise
I don't go they so when the I I always
think worst case scenario I know but I
hadn't gone to the doctor and I don't
know I had throat cancer remember I was
like yeah I remember all this and I
think it was like a chance of my throat
yeah it was like a piece of kale I have
[__] uh I thought it was the Black
Plague I can't do the podcast
like Speck on your forehead you thought
it was cancerous that well yeah I did
because I had one cancerous yeah uh
squamous cell on my back yeah I don't
all that [__]
we didn't talk about it because we we
didn't talk about the fights during the
fight World [__] going on because we had
the boys from uh yeah Super Troopers on
yeah but uh what I find interesting is
whenever
anybody outside the UFC announces a
fight what it is Dana rushes to the War
Room go all right how can we Trump this
and for the first time ever he can't do
that because so Francis and Tyson Fury
got announced legit fight it's a legit
fight it's in Saudi Arabia they're
throwing all the money at Francis
Francis won no matter how you play it he
could go out there and get knocked out
in three seconds France Francis is one
he's won yeah he did exactly what he
said he was gonna do I said and he won
yeah it's great now there was some dicey
things that were like what's happening
but in the boxing World takes forever to
come will this be a real fight though
it's not an exhibition so you know why
you're saying is it exhibition is it
what's going on here how that term
exhibition got started when that's just
that's the fight World [__] on
somebody doing well Eddie Hearns the one
who released that Eddie Hearn Frank
Warren who put the fight together it's
his arch nemesis so right when the
Rumblings he goes oh it's not a real
fight so that gets out in the media now
what are you saying it's not a real
fight what's Dana saying it's not a real
fight it's just [__] on them because
they're not part of it that's all fake
that's not real
they're gonna kill you somebody's
getting knocked out somebody's going
yeah this is a fight it's all real so
you got to be careful I mean you're not
going to take Francis you know what it's
like it's like in uh in politics when
remember when Hunter Biden stuff came
out and all of a sudden the submarine
takes the news oh but look at look the
submarines doing this look at all this
don't worry about that the submarine's
doing this that's what's going on here
yeah but and then we find out but the
submarine we know for a fact you guys
knew it everyone died on Sunday you
allowed this to go on even though we
knew yeah what can you do 100 by odds in
the past so all they leaked this stuff
to to just distract you from what's
going on when is that Eddie Hearn goes
oh look it's but yeah they got the deal
done whatever but it's gonna be it's not
a real fight so then all these [__]
sheep run with that and pair it the same
[__] right not real just it's not your
fault you don't nobody would know as
much your balls deep in the game but
Eddie Hearn it's and Daniel White's
gonna do the same thing get into his
announcements but for the first time
ever thanks
Danny can go to the War Room whether
it's pfl who whatever League's Bellator
and he can Trump him yeah he can Trump
everything he would look at this matchup
because they have the biggest Fighters
yeah first time ever they can't there's
one uh can you guess there's one fight
they can announce now before you tell me
remember too
Fury and Tyson uh Tyson Fury and Francis
are fighting two weeks before Jon Jones
and steepe so I got two questions for
you
two questions
are you more excited for Tyson Fury
Francis or Stipe Jon Jones
Tyson Fury not even close not even Up
For Debate is there anybody in here
that's more excited for a steepe who
hasn't fought in a thousand days over a
thousand days in his last fight was
against Francis
is anyone more excited for that
no right so let me ask you this so
you're more excited Clary for that
they're two weeks apart so the Tyson
Fury is going to Trump the Jon Jones
stuff
is it can you name a fight there's one
fight
can you name a fight that UFC could put
together that would Trump Tyson Fury and
Francis ingano
if you're in the boardroom with Dana and
all the people today and they go what
are we gonna do man this Tyson Fury is
happening Francis he makes us look bad
how can we Trump this what do you want
to do Dan goes anybody got any ideas
what's your idea well the idea would be
the obvious idea would be Nate Diaz uh
way off so off all right
it's not even Nate Diaz over Tyson Fury
get out now with uh with Jake Paul no
and they're and they're they're not in
the UFC Brian yeah okay so we're talking
real [__] you're saying real fight yeah
okay hold on hold on don't give me like
Mel Gibson
no real [__] dude like you're I mean you
really want to get crazy if we're doing
this it's Brock Lesnar Jon Jones nope
okay I wouldn't beat it hold on hold on
an old Brock Lesnar hold on so you're
saying you're getting that one's closer
you're headed in the right direction
there is a fight they can make yeah that
would be bigger that would get more
traction more eyeballs would Trump any
fight anybody can make well uh does it
involve uh it either involves Conor
McGregor or Ronda Rousey nope
Elon Musk boom oh [__] Elon Musk and
[__] there's still one fight they can
make that aren't legit Fighters I
thought we were talking about Fighters
here but Dana's in that business oh I
got you so if you're in the boardroom I
guarantee like they're going around
there's not a fighter on the roster that
they put together that can Trump Tyson
and Francis but someone's like hey Dana
you talked to Mark right and he's like
yeah and they were just training with
Alex uh volkanovsky and Izzy in uh
California right he's like yeah and
elon's training with the guys
yeah what's the chance of them fighting
before you know this year Zuckerberg I
know he's freaking Zuckerberg's [__]
in shape
he's in shape that's the one fight they
can make that would Trump Tyson Fury and
Francis that's it there's no legit
fighters on the roster there's no legit
one verse one you know interim champ one
verse two one verse three even hamzat
verse you know whoever you want is he
wouldn't Trump this I don't think so
he's over there in New Zealand training
with those no no they're in La buddy
okay they're in California they're in
NorCal party oh they're in Lake Tahoe
I just talked to act they're in Lake
Tahoe wow
um but the point is is don't get
distracted by his body please but the
point is please take that down but the
point is is okay man isn't that crazy
like that's the one fight they can make
that with Trump but that's it I don't
think Elon Musk is ready for that
neither of them are ready what do you
mean oh you think zuckers because you
saw him training because he looks lean
yeah there's one problem you can't fight
dude he's also yeah it's gonna be but
the point is that's the one fight the
UFC I don't want a good mate by the way
I don't want to see but the problem is
everyone does yeah and if like there's
more I don't think casuals does it
I don't think the fight really comes to
fruition if they do it's this weird
gimmicky thing but let's say if it was a
real fight that's the one fight that if
Dana's gonna put his foot down and try
to get some to Trump Francis being
successful which he always does every
time always does this tries to take away
the shine try to call a gimmick but all
that's out the window because remember
even before this there's Romans that
this was going to be announced what did
Dana do we're trying to do Jon Jones
Tyson the UFC what remember that no
that's real no that's real it's just
them trying to distract you from Francis
making the right choice it's all smoke
and mirrors no that's real John and
Tyson are never gonna find anything they
can do anyway it's like good luck and
Elon would destroy it it would
absolutely annihilate it annihilate any
fight it might just make everybody a
fight fan Am I who everybody I mean
everybody's gonna want to watch both
fights now that is must see TV Tyson
Fury Francis and Ghana right everybody
wants to see that it's not the same as
Elon vs Zuckerberg one is more sport the
other spectacle so one's entertainment
one sport you know so but so it's the
only fight the UFC can for the sound
history make that would actually Trump
another organization before they've
always been able to do it now they can't
how weird how cool is it Francis put him
in this situation and he's one no matter
what like if even if Francis goes in
there gets knocked out in three seconds
from a jab from Fury he won he made he
made all the money right in Saudi Arabia
they have all the [__] money so the
bags he's gonna get is insane yeah and
then the pfl stuff at this point
whatever that was just like yeah I'm
doing this here's an announcement but
then allow me to fight the the MMA stuff
after this doesn't matter it's all hyper
no but it's not even hype it doesn't
matter this is the only thing that
matters what is this uh I I had a
conversation with Brandon a while ago
about the whole Elon Musk thing right
how you know people that don't know
about will know about it my parents
don't know [__] about Elon Musk or
Zuckerberg so my parents are talking to
my so so visit me and Chin's argument
hold on position Chin's argument is hold
on positive Chin's argument is that if
Elon fights more people are gonna sign
up for Facebook no that's not my
argument no you said it brings it brings
more attention to him so whatever you
want to bring so it's going to bring
more people to whatever he wants to do I
said Facebook can't get anything it
right but anyways my parents don't know
[__] about any of this stuff and so my
dad started talking about it and I just
recorded how did you know this Dad he
said
how did you even find out
[Music]
my mom's going to talk about it
wow so you never heard about them before
right yeah no nobody don't know but then
now you know about them is he gonna
start on Facebook yeah I'm gonna start
on Facebook you did I'm just I'm just
freaking out that my parents they don't
know anything let me ask you this thing
do they know about Tyson Fury Francis no
not a chance
wow like my dad knows my dad knows about
Elon and Mark Zuckerberg it's so crazy
he doesn't even know that the Tyson Fury
fight got announced that's good it's
insane you're talking but it's just a
it's just a different thing yeah I mean
you're you're I mean there you
motorcycle were in Elon Musk two of the
most famous billionaires I mean it
doesn't get their hands down the most I
mean they're more famous than any
Hollywood celebrity 100 the you know how
big Facebook is I mean you know yeah
it's not and how about Instagram and
WhatsApp and you know they own all of
that meta it's nuts right yeah this is
famous that's the only fight the UFC can
make to my point it's only thing one
point for the first time ever yeah
they've always been able to beat
everybody and bring up if they do Izzy
hamzat you know John Brock they vote hey
we got Rhonda guys I'm gonna take a
little break here and um if you want to
go see me at the Blue Room in
Springfield
Springfield uh Missouri I'll be at the
Blue Room July 21 July 22 and then I'm
at The Improv in Ontario right here
right here in the South Bay Los Angeles
uh Friday July 28th and July 29th
Saturday and then cap cities
August three four and five that's going
to be exciting
um
I I think I ate macadamia nuts every day
now they're the most expensive and
rarest of nuts
um one percent of the market in nuts
they grow in very few climates but South
Africa is one of them and they're about
90 plus Farmers that work together to
create the best macadamia nuts on the
planet it helps rural South African
communities and their struggling economy
and how some Academia is who works with
all these companies and they've got the
best nuts they have hand dipped you know
sugar-free chocolate white chocolate
um uh like Cherry it's it's crazy and no
added sugar no artificial ingredients
they got the Macadamia snack bars and
the snack bars are 45 of the snack bar
is macadamia nuts they got blueberry
they got coconut
um it's unbelievable
so um they've also got these amazing nut
Butters and cold pressed extra virgin
macadamia nut oil which is what I cook
with now because it's got a buttery
flavor and and it's got a high smoke
point so when I'm cooking a steak I
bring that oil up to the surface of the
Sun and it doesn't change its
composition doesn't turn bitter and you
can fry steak in that oh you see her
steak in macadamia nut butter it's it's
actually
decadent and outrageous so go to House
of macadamia House of
macadamias.com Slash T fat fak so House
of macadamias.com t f a k plus 20 off
uh your your entire order with code tfak
okay and you'll get a free box of
macadamia snack bars try them I promise
you will become addicted we always have
them in the office and I don't think I
go a day without eating them
which is why my skin looks so
insanely Supple and Young
I have Macadamia skin
all right I said it
has macadamus.comtfak
you know I'm talking about making a
comeback did I hear that she hasn't but
the stars align where her contract the
WWE is up man nuna's out of the
conference we're out of the UFC she's
retired so you know you gotta do an
opinion there not a bad fight for Rhonda
Pena
Ron is you know she's in shape yeah
she's in shape
she's in shape from the WWE so
uh if I had to bet on it I bet you UFC
300 Ronda Rousey Giuliana Pena are you
serious that's what I think I have no
inside information here wow
I'm just saying that's what I would do
why are you smiling um because I think
that's if I'm the UFC I gotta pull out
some big dogs but you just went like
this to me
and well I didn't wink at you I've just
known you a long time and when you go
like that I feel like there's maybe some
information you have maybe a little
smoke I don't know we'll see okay now
maybe maybe UFC 300 might be too fast no
I'm not breaking news listen I'm not I'm
not saying you are I'm saying if I was
part of the UFC brass I look at Rhonda's
contract I look at the state of the
division right now Julian opinion is a
good matchup for Ronda okay they've
they've won to fight each other Pena has
called her out before Rhonda has some
unfinished business the way she left the
UFC is probably one of the worst
exitings of the UFC she does that
doesn't sit right with her I don't think
you should you know like she's such a
better person than that no how old is
Rhonda now
36 okay
Stella killer
big time
um
Okay so
there you go interesting but even if the
UFC announced Rhonda back over opinion
doesn't Trump very Francis no
no way right
um the boxing world's mad at it like
Tyson Fury should be fighting news sick
and Josh was like ah it's all bollocks
this is [__] that's a fake fight all
right
yeah
the odds did come out Tyson was a minus
400 which was weird that's just somebody
[__] up so everyone jumped on it he
jumped they're like minus a thousand yes
or after he's gonna be like a minus four
thousand to be honest different sport
tough male was minus one thousand oh
that's Jones never mind
that's Jon Jones
um
yeah boxing's easier a lot of times free
open on minus one thousand there was a
betting site because my boy bet on it he
put all his money on it Christopher is
minus four minus 400 is it holy [__] so
he took Francis put like whatever 15
grand on it and then as soon as they did
that they literally the two minutes
later I was like hold on it's minus a
thousand so does that mean his BET's no
good no it's good they just [__] up oh
wow or they're trying to get movement
wow I also heard something so Ariel
posted a video and then he said
something like
if I have any more
oh here it is so just listen to what he
says here
he can Fury in a fight that is under
boxing rules in a boxing ring no
gimmicks no gloves no gloves
oh he messed up there saying no he he
met no MMA gloves yeah okay it's not
bear enough because he was a Sonic
gimmick you know there's no gloves but
he he just he was saying there's no MMA
yeah okay that's all that is because
remember before and even jail talked
about like you know don't do an octagon
don't box with four ounce gloves make it
a real boxing match that's what Ariel's
saying they're like this it's not a
gimmick it's a real [__] box to match
they're in boxing gloves we don't know
the rounds yet but I'm sure to be you
know eight to ten let me say 10 rounds
and I don't know if I think people are
getting caught up again the the Hearns
of the world and Dana's gonna point to
this say it's a gimmick but they're like
yeah Tyson Fury's belt's not even on the
line
I don't give a [__] who cares would you
care if Alex walkenowski and uh yeah
Rodriguez if the belts are on the line
you know you just want to fight yeah and
then the baddest man on the planet we're
gonna know give whatever belch WBO
whatever I don't give a [__] yeah it's
gonna be very clear who the winner is
yeah but that's all stuff they're gonna
try and harp on you know
um now who do you give more of a chance
to
in the fight and well here
Floyd Mayweather Connor right they're
lighter so it's different yeah or
Francis against Fury did did Floyd have
a better chance I'm sorry did Connor
have a better chance against Floyd now
you're talking about the greatest
defensive box of all time uh he's about
equal I don't think so I mean I don't
think uh Francis does anything to I mean
look um remember Tyson Fury has dealt
with very Heavy Hitters all those guys
Deontay Wilder yeah twice and a lot of
dudes and so
um I think that uh
I just think that it's it's really
really hard for Francis to the Tyson
Fury can get Francis where he wants him
to hit him he's going to get him he's
going to dictate everything here's why
it's different here's what that's clear
but here's why it's different Francis I
don't care who you are Tyson Fury
it's over so he has that Conor never had
that no Connor's doesn't he doesn't have
that one knockout power over Floyd
Francis even if even if he's getting
Molly watt for eight rounds and but he
lands one game I mean look at Alistair
over him
uh Fair debate he's by far the best
Striker to ever grace the UFC Octagon
the heavyweight division K1 Champion
Elite level Striker yeah have you seen
one Francis did his tooth go flying or
something no no but his his brain did
yeah his brain left his body got
uppercut so in his boxing so Tyson's
gonna get hit now what kind of hit he
takes I don't know I mean obviously
Tyson's way more
um skilled so he you know let's see what
he does all I'm saying is you would have
to side with France as a better chance
of beating Tyson than Conor ever had to
beat Floyd because they're so they
because they're heavyweights yeah and
anything can happen yeah anything can
happen and not only can anything happen
you're talking about the hardest hitting
UFC fighter of all time who is training
Francis for this fight is it Teddy Atlas
no
yeah same team he doesn't have a boxing
guy I'm sure he does but his coach
um and it remember it's an October
season start his training camp he's in
Africa I think
see let's see homeboys let's see if he
hits with some power he's such a freak
you say let's see if he hits with power
yeah see how let's see if he's got any
power in his punches what I'm trying to
say you should critique him dude yeah
bring the videos of Francis box and have
Brian let me see him hitting the bag is
what I'm trying to say go up isn't it
that's the picture yeah
well I I'm gonna go on a limit I think
he gets hard I think he's hard yeah yeah
it's better when I hear you critique him
I I just don't think we need it yeah
I do think Francis he has more of a
advantage to win than Connor did because
because that one hit knockout power then
there are heavyweights
so kudos to Tyson for even [__]
taking it that's the highlight of it
yeah these are always [__] you don't
learn anything off that yeah anybody who
watches guys hit backs go I don't know
man seems off like oh you're casual yeah
yeah yeah
boxing in a ring is very different
um
yeah it's gonna be uh I can't wait
October's gonna be great yeah October's
gonna be [__] lit would be
interesting to watch I think France
isn't gonna speed is what surprised a
lot of people
so [__] fast
you know that's part of where his power
comes from yeah I don't know if it's you
know surprise Tyson because Tyson's
faster than him
faster but I think Tyson I think Tyson's
much better no Tyson's a quicker boxer
yeah quicker yeah his hands are better
oh yeah then then uh Tyson Fury yeah the
best ever do it yeah yeah I don't think
that's what makes Tyson Fury so good I
think what makes tests I think it's a
number of things skill but I don't know
the types of your area is really fast
hands oh man for his size oh yeah yeah
for his size but I don't think they're
faster than Francis and Ghana oh I do
especially when it comes to boxing yeah
for sure no I don't know about that at
all but I'll say this
um his yeah he knows where you're going
he knows what you're doing
look at that look at that nuts yeah like
that I see it
years and years of just that that's
[__] nuts come on
it's beautiful laughing
he does not give yeah I think fairy's
the best we've ever seen yeah yeah yeah
I mean it's gonna be great
but doing that with Francis zangano is
different
with your hands down that'd be very
dangerous
very [__] dangerous it's gonna be
easier for them to do it against Francis
well because that guy's a better box
than France correct yeah like he's a
professional boxer Brian right yeah yeah
it's still and I I yeah Francis might be
fast in the first round but he's not you
know some of his punches are quick but
they're very loopy and yeah
yeah Tyson much more efficient he's got
that uppercut he's got a pretty good
uppercut which is I think that's how he
knocked out Alice yeah yeah so that came
fast take a look at that that's such a
fast uppercut boom it was like
astonishing
um
yeah
so what do you think of the fights uh
nothing surprising everything surprising
what
we can't show this stuff definitely
can't show it
though oh geez
announcer goes to the left hook
boom Oh my God oh my God oh my one of
the worst Knockouts in UFC history oh my
God I hate that and I hate that he hit
him when he was down like that that's so
dangerous it was tough he went he went
to sleep oh [__] dude yeah
oof
thank God you're out of that [__]
alistair's doing the fasting now no boys
skinny
so uh Alexander volkanovsky pound for
pound in the top three best of all time
what do you think he's been he's the
best one in 45 of all time he's been
tested like by everyone yeah great
wrestler like Max Holloway three times
nuts everybody everybody
Rodriguez is no [__] joke but
arguably the best the second best 45 in
the world um
no no who else
um I mean he's [__] good he's up
there you know but
there's just said it a long time ago you
said that [__] doesn't work against the
really good guys
not when it comes to uh volkanovsky
besides just those kicks those awesome
kicks all that flying stuff what can I
see is so much better than everybody
he's just there's nobody what is it that
makes him so good he just everything
well his game plan he adapts well he
does everything well so wherever you
want to do any damage like I haven't
seen him take any damage like think
about all the fights he's had or taking
one he was a little beat up not really
man he beat the [__] [__] out of
Ortega he did be there all right
yeah okay let's go [__] he's just so
much better than everybody
barely losing the Islam
Max Holloway
Korean zombie Brian Ortega Max Holloway
Max Holloway again Josie Aldo I mean
people think some people think he won
against Islam I did too but it was
[__] close and I was I want to see it
again that's if I don't see it I don't
care for him at 45 anymore just too dumb
yeah dominant there's no 45 is going to
beat him the period is not going to beat
him he's got a 55.
yeah we could bring up 55 let me see
who's in that weight class he's gonna
have everybody's gonna have their hands
full everybody yeah Dustin poor gay
Chief fighting at the end of the month
yeah but Charles Oliveira would be I
think that his toughest matchup
with his finishing and his his skill set
but his wrestling's just not there
you know Alex just beat everybody man
he's so [__] good
Jesus the biggest uh upset was by far
um DDP
yeah
they beat Whitaker yeah well it felt
like Whitaker there was something going
on with Whitaker that's the problem
that's why I saw in the shop show that's
the problem it's not what you know
workers he's been on a streak yeah he's
been beating the [__] out of it it's
it's that's how good DDP is the police
he's so good he's so awkward going back
to school he's like I don't know what
the [__] to do is that what he said he
was literally you can tell he's just
looking like I don't know what the
[__] going on here he knocked him down
with like a kind of a straight jab yeah
he's a big dude awkward you've never
seen it yeah so you got to be careful
with that because like uh Robert
Ricker's older no no it just looks like
no no what's going on that's that do
police makes everybody look like that
and now his cardio's better now did can
he pull it off against is he oh man I
want to see it but he's doing something
[__] right man yeah
he's just awkward as [__] it looks like
he like you and if you had a young kid
you wouldn't show him the video of DDP
and go that's how you fight because it's
all it's like he's going downhill like
different angles and it's just it's just
weird like the whole thing for him it
works for I don't know if it worked for
anybody else yeah just this weird style
that nobody sees and Robert Whittaker
once again he looked older now he looked
pretty quick you just couldn't land [__]
you know yeah
yeah see so you know I wonder if there's
an injury or anything that he wasn't
talking about or something was up no we
got to stop doing that dude police is so
good
he got beat you know
he's just got beat yeah
you know we always take away from guys
looked off he actually he's fighting
Greek his new policies that it's so
[__] awkward none of this stuff was
working some of the light kicks he had
success with his left hook with a high
Guard from duplicity's just wasn't
Landing she usually lands
and they hit so [__] hard once he did
hit him it was over man God he's a
[__] thick dude that big dude Jesus I
don't realize how big he is yikes
[__] thick long arms boom it's a big
dude and then Bo nickel uh Bo Nichols is
uh how good is he just you know
impossible I mean yeah I mean that's a
guy that would burn I mean the guy was
cutting Lawns made me sad but but you
know um but Bill Nichols a guy who has
been hardwired to compete since he was
nine years old he's been watching the
human body move you know he's also had
pressure since he was eight that's what
I mean he showed me a video he's like 10
in front of 2 000 people wrestling at
10. it's like the uh DC it's like Daniel
Cormier when you're an Olympian and and
he wasn't but he was a I think
three-time NCAA champ he was a hodge
winner too that's a Heisman for yeah
you're talking about uh you're just
talking about a complete freak but we've
had that before like the wrestling
credentials don't really sell me yeah
it's his way you can put everything
together and dominate like DC didn't
dominate like this
Phil Davis didn't dominate like we've
had great wrestlers they didn't dominate
who's Beau Nichols biggest uh besides
Izzy who's who's his biggest challenge
[Music]
who do you think is next for a bow
nickel whoever they want
you know they're moving they're playing
this is very surprising it's not
surprising that's what they should be
doing yeah I agree they should be but
they haven't done that in the past but
they've been doing that because they
deal with sugar Shawn they've done that
with other guys with body pamlet they've
learned from them yeah it's a marathon
not a Sprint so
um like you're telling me that bonica
wouldn't be favored he wouldn't be the
favorite over do policies right now
I mean
would you not bet on Beau over duplicate
only just because of I don't know what
duplicate does when Bo grabs him
you know you wouldn't favor Bo for Alex
Pierre right now
uh I would no no I'm not I'm taking Beau
all day you you wouldn't take Bo Nick
over Jared counting here right now 100
you wouldn't take Bo Nick over Marvin
Victoria right now you wouldn't take
Beau nickel over Sean Strickland right
now
you wouldn't take Beau nickel over Paulo
Costa right now Derek Brunson show me
who beats him out of those guys I just
mentioned
now we don't know because he hasn't
fought at that level but from what we've
seen I just I don't know how they're
going to navigate his wrestling but you
didn't have to use against guy who cuts
lawns I would say the only thing that
would happen is you have a guy who's so
competitive like Bo nickel but also very
smart if Bo nickel decides let me see
how my hands work no yes that's why you
got to love him because he's not that
guy no he doesn't he's too smart for him
yeah he's not gonna just go let me see
if I can stand and bang with you know
Alex Pierre he's Captain America dude
yeah
I know I'm all up on his Nittany line
nuts but no it's I have to see him I'm
just like how do you deal with that we
haven't had a he's like our LeBron dude
yeah it's just you look at and I with
the UFC it's like this might be the
first time like we can toss him to the
[__] walls and I think he's gonna
pass the test where we really haven't
had that right so it's like are they
gonna give us another guy who's whatever
five and four in the UFC he's kind of
this veteran I don't want to see that is
he calling for anybody he's just quiet
he's like I don't know he's been calling
for Hamza when he was on here one Hamza
even before he was in the UFC he's like
I'll destroy homside like is that what
he said yeah yeah he's like what's he
gonna do wrestle me
I'm like it's hard to argue you're like
yeah you're right like you're just
getting this train that's all
press six one six two yeah six six one
but big like he walks around pretty big
right about two I don't know I don't
care about size he's so [__] skilled
like all those guys unless you're just
unless you're a freak Size Doesn't
Matter like yeah let's use some outlier
like six seven enough
well he's at 170 right no I think he's
uh 85. no he's 170 is he yeah he is yes
only been at 70.
no I'm thinking about another guy at 85.
um
yeah I mean I guess there's times out
yeah but homicide's fighting Cannon
there Canada's coach accidentally leaked
it on his Instagram so getting ready for
the next fight and it was Hamza and
that's gonna be in uh I think Abu Dhabi
when they don't go in Abu Dhabi in
August or some October it's still like
Hamza hasn't fought in forever I don't
know what's going on there but so like
Bo Hamza you like
if they announce I'm like that's sick
you wouldn't be like oh my God what are
they doing
the likes of Bo nickel
who internationally just like oh yeah
what international team was he on like
just guys in Chinese and he wrestled in
the I think he wrestled in the European
circuit comes out right
so he's seen he's seen you know the
Dagestan he's seen the that's completely
different that's completely different
than what boat does you know what you
know what but you know Bose never lost
those guys you know he Tech Falls those
guys
well I think somebody asked him
about the dagestanis and he was like
yeah yeah I did and yeah I did I said
what are you gonna do there's this
onslaught of Dexter and he goes oh where
because I've never wrestled against them
all my life I mean how do you do against
me he's like never lost
I love it yeah I love it so it's not to
October 21st so that's when you're
getting throwing him anything he hasn't
seen a lot of times
well he hasn't seen a striker like Izzy
that's that's right he hasn't seen a guy
like Robert Whittaker you know like that
he hasn't seen that high high level
where you take him down a lot of these
guys you're fine now take him down
they're gonna break and you're gonna
find uh you know an easy submission yeah
and that you're not getting that on Izzy
you're not getting on Hamza you know I
get on those vets like you're gonna have
to earn it but again he has the mental
capacity where okay yeah you know he's
not gonna be one of those guys like oh
my God this didn't work or I didn't
achieve a takedown first one oh no he's
I feel like he's good yeah for the first
time ever I feel very confident in this
guy
you should he's only been winning his
whole life at wrestling though yeah but
that he does have a championship mindset
but again though he's also down it's
good to have that rest he's not down top
team he's so good they open no they open
a top team for him in Pittsburgh or in
Pennsylvania really in Pennsylvania
because he was mentioning Mike Brown and
all the guys down they go no they go up
there oh boy yeah he has his own [__]
he's in Pittsburgh no a Pennsylvania
right but right next to the Nittany
Lions Camp oh boy yeah he's so good they
built the ATT around him who are his
training partners he flies who cares
dude yeah you know
I know he said he still wrestles with
the Yale team he goes there and wrestles
all the time some of the Nittany lines
that are uh like all Americans he
wrestles them they're getting the MMA
like he has This heavyweight he rolls
with he's a Savage
he's a good he has a good team
wow yeah if you're the UFC I wonder what
you do with him next you know
I just have to I don't feel top 10 yet
because you got to build the story
because he's still not I mean he has his
fan base but I think you go like
mouthpiece I I think you have a guy
who's gonna talk [__] to him who's who's
establishing his name who you might be
out of top 15 and then you go you
wouldn't give him Victoria no no no no
no no because because that's so
short-sighted because then I he beats
him if he destroys a Marvin Victoria all
right then it's Off to the Races and
also remember he's not getting paid like
to fight like Marvin Victoria's he's not
getting paid to fight top five so for
both it's like you don't have to build
them up for if both from a business
standpoint well why am I gonna fight
Sean Strickland when I'm getting paid
like I'm not in the top 15. so let me
fight whatever cans you want until I
write out this contract then we're gonna
argue just to work out the contract and
just get more experience for the UFC
well why would they give a guy who has
three fights the same contract to give a
guy like Sean Strickland that's 30. the
UFC can't do that because they don't
know they're not going a bank on him
being the Savage and he got to earn into
yeah so as soon as and he's down to
Earnest as soon as you're seeing you go
okay we're gonna give you top five guys
like cool my contract's up so this is
paying me top five money you don't want
to like like when I was five how many
more fights when I started when I was
fighting no so many when I was fighting
crocod when I was fighting no Guerra I
wasn't getting paid to fight those guys
it's getting paid like a normal like
yeah how many more fights do you think
he just signed with them dude so what
are they signed to six fight deal
now he's paid more than about three
times now I think uh twice he's paid
more than like a normal like guy if you
just came off the contender Series yeah
because he's bow nickel but he's still
not getting paid like top five money
right like you want that top five money
Beast to fight those top five guys
he's fought uh are those in the UFC no
okay he slept twice
the container series don't count as UFC
fights I mean they're fights but it's
not like UFC level you're the Apex
Center nobody's watching
um so you see four more fights of guys
in the Box no not four not four no no no
you give them what two more fights with
this because the UFC is going to
renegotiate before you even get to your
last fight he's got to be in the top 15.
you got to give him guys in the top 15.
yeah if I'm Bo I'm like no pay me my
money okay it's a business
you know add a bonus or something
I mean otherwise what are we doing what
do you mean he only has two fights too
he's young too this is the problem
though the pressure people put on these
Fighters like Patty pimlet or even even
with Jake Paul it's like we want to see
Universe Canal it's like Jesus Christ
that's hilarious yeah but he with Bo
nickel it's like nah man until you get
paid Millions don't fight first he's got
more to learn striking and all that for
damn sure so how do you know we don't
know yeah that's a that's a big learning
curve but he's been doing it for four
years now five years everyone you tell
everyone in the business that goes this
kid can [__] strike look what he did
to [__] wood Burn yeah lit his ass up
knock them out yeah
dude we just don't know how good he is
and what level we know he's [__] good
but we don't know what level of good yet
yeah because he hasn't fought a guy who
can put up any sort of fight yeah
I'd like to see him fight kamza
no because then he's fighting for a
championship do you think that happens
a year a year I give him a year before
he's fighting top five
that's fair and they're holding him at
the gates though because he's there and
he wants it oh yeah but if if I'm his
manager I'm like this I'm holding him at
the gates no no no no yeah and then
we're releasing the hounds and making
all the money
otherwise you talk about this all the
time these guys you know it's a marathon
not a Sprint and we want to see these
fights what happens if he gets clipped
dude and he's fighting for whatever 30
and 30. anyone makes 30 grand all right
well you lost him well you still got a
name so he just lost a Whitaker yeah all
right here's Hamza all right you lose
that one now you make another 30 grand
okay now now it's a toughest or we just
play this right keep banking the wins
get experience and when you want to be
Champion don't hold that belt forever
do it that way dude don't be in a rush
no they did it right with Sean O'Malley
yeah exactly
um Sean's getting paid to fight those
top guys yeah
yeah
um
no man
I love when there's a prospect like this
makes sport fun
yeah
what do you got Jen
's liver problems you're excited about
too please
yeah I like the racial component of it
it's hilarious I know
look guys I am a I used to not be into
supplements because uh you know I talked
to some people and then I then I had
some scientists look under my hood
Andy Galpin Dan Garner
um and uh they put me on a supplement
protocol and
I called my my dear friend Mr Joe Rogan
and I said hey dude supplements they I
feel so good he goes yeah dude I've been
telling you yes I know I know don't tell
me that I was something I've been saying
to you for since I was 30. so I'm I'm
always slow to the game but if you want
the best supplements on planet Earth and
they have literally everything from fish
oil they have krill oil they've got
Alpha Brain so you want your nootropics
they've got different Alpha brains
they've got Alpha Brain Black which is
the strong one which a lot of people I
know who are high functioning Square by
you got you if you want better sleep
they've got new mood they've got
melatonin spray they got vitamin D3
spray they've got gut health things for
your gut health they've got everything
you can think of honestly and as
somebody who used to be a little
skeptical I am now a convert because I
felt the difference so if you want the
best supplements on planet if you want
uncompromised quality it's on it it's
always been on it they've been our
longest standing sponsor so go to on
it.com slash F A
t k
on it.com slash f-a-t-k
for 10 off everything
man I would love if someone uh miked up
Trump
what are you saying when he kept saying
the n word Trump was like what is
happening what's going on here
what is happening here thank you for
your vote is duplicity is not from
Florida like no no that's why they're
using the N word that's why there's this
animosity the record I would never do
that folks isn't it weird
I want them to stop and you know what's
going on there right do policies was
saying you're not a real African
oh is that what he's saying yeah oh you
don't know the backstory so before going
he was saying you're not a real African
you're in you're from New Zealand I'm a
real African I'm gonna show you how
Africans fight and then he's like hold
up dude I was born in Nigeria I moved to
New Zealand when I was a kid I got
bullied for being African what the [__]
are you talking about yeah so I'm black
yeah but he's just saying I was like do
police saying I was born raised in
Africa live in Africa you know I pay my
taxes in Africa if they pay taxes he's
like you know so he's like I'm a real
Afghan and that gets dicey when a man of
lighter skin says that to another man
who has dark skin when you're of now I
think the police now do policies
managers said that and when you see
duplicity in the hot guy he's kind of
like oh this isn't this is what I wanted
yeah he didn't want to deal with that oh
and you could tell is he probably
drinking a little bit probably didn't
think it all the way through kept saying
36 and it might have been might have
been drinking still my faith might have
been still love them yeah but he he was
heated but is he wanted that's also his
boy his boy just got beat up Sir no no
no no Izzy was rooting for depletes he
he before the fight he was like please
do please he's win this [__] place he
wants to fight he's already yeah and he
wants to fight he wants fresh blood
there's a story I'm gonna ask a dumb
question are Whitaker I thought Whitaker
and our boy uh is he they're not in the
same camp no yeah I don't know why I
thought that because they're both in New
Zealand I was like oh Robert no one's
from Australia one's New Zealand two
different countries right yeah
there we go
there we go yeah
forgot about that
[__] with it correct a little stupid
huh no I'm not saying it's confusing a
little bit right I get how you can think
that I was like okay I don't know why
but I thought for some reason yeah that
was the case all three of them by the
way I'll tell you who got amped it was
Izzy got amped might have been some
alcohol or it just could have been good
old-fashioned testosterone yeah in fact
I said 36 and maybe something I get it
man you're flying off the cuff you know
you kept saying the n word yeah it was
awkward but almost awkward interview of
also awkward it's one of the most
awkward you know what's happening if you
tell the police like I watched it first
without sound and then I saw it with
sound I was like oh boy
I think duplicates woke up a sleeping
giant and and the police I think he's
like yeah we don't go down that road the
you know the the you know the culture
War whatever and is he's like oh no
we're going there you said it he's like
yeah I know but I want to take that back
no no you said it like this is not gonna
let it go I think he woke up a [__]
Sleeping Giant in his senior [__] up
that's what's gonna happen oh but yeah
the police he's so [__] awkward
and Savage who know like you can't just
say he is he's gonna walk through him
I'm done I'm done doubting DDP yeah when
you see style when he did Whittaker
which is insane which I think is the
worst matchup from 45 before Whitaker he
fought uh Darren till and then he fought
Jeff he fought uh Brunson yeah
and what's interesting is the Darren
Taylor fight
could have lost that fight easily didn't
look great yeah Derek Brunson could have
lost that fight too he was losing those
fights the Rob Whitaker he got this
surgery he has cardio now
as belief in himself
so he's the real African boom we got a
title fight yeah that African stuff is
dying see dude and I don't know the lay
the land in South Africa I I look at my
[__] manager and be like hey bro xn
not me if I'm the manager I go but did
we get the fight he did get the fight
you did get the fight yeah you got the
attack because remember he was ranked
like 10 or something at that time when
they kept talking [__] and people were
like there's no dude please never gonna
fight was he this man is like hold up
yeah hold my [__] bear we're real
Africans he's like whoa he's like you
want the fight or not I'm gonna take
some hits you want the fight or not dude
wasn't wasn't uh wasn't it Kobe
Covington after the fight he goes you
know I had to sell the fight right you
know obviously who was he saying that to
tomorrow
yeah
all right what do you got Jen
um just a couple more MMA stuff Kevin
Lee
just suddenly retired
they did him dirty said you're coming
back very cool we're glad to have you
back here's a terrible matchup I got
starts man starts yeah I've decided
retire from my UFC it's been 12 years 12
long years of me being the best fight I
can be
he said he's done he had a good career I
think part of it like some people are
sad it's like we you know Kevin Lee with
his skill set you thought he was gonna
be champ yeah you know so some people
like ah man what a whatever they might
have some sort of dark cloud I wish a
great career man 12 years I thought
everybody dude and retiring with not as
much damage as a lot of guys do I think
it's great at 30 years and he believes
in himself says he takes that skill set
hard work to a different thing right
that's smart at 30. he's a smart kid too
man yeah he's a great guy too yeah you
can talk handsome's [__] handsome as
[__] yeah yeah he's awesome congrats I
would love by the way for the record
would love to be built that way you look
jacked that is he short he's short how
tall is he
five eight bring them up you've met him
many of times five nine yeah he's
fighting at 55.
yeah but he's he's he's awesome Jack big
dick who's winning man you know that
thing's popping too Daddy I would
imagine he's got some a piece on him
yeah now I believe he's mixed correct
black and Asian
Kevin I don't know we gave away that the
last name Lee
do you think I'm just saying did the
last name Lee get because I like where
you're going necessarily in some people
background uh
um he's got a little bit of an Asian
look to him he's got it but he could be
just black yeah
I'm very happy with the space yeah he
has a little bit of uh like he'd be Ben
Henderson's kid right
or or Dan Henderson's kid you never know
very wide face
in a good way
um last name Lee those very but these
are people who are there are people who
are have that last name who are no Asian
in them but that's like who parents are
Harvey Lee Oswald well so Lee is
actually well his last name's Oswald no
there are different people who have I
know but give me one famous One
um a famous person his last name is Lee
uh I'm [__] Steve Lee
Chung Lee
Steve Lee
uh there's me some white guy named Lee
there's a football player namely white
boy now there are people who have uh
Spike Lee there you go oh Jason Lee oh
yeah Peg Stanley Stanley's the best
example yeah you guys Christopher Lee
you guys are stupid huh yeah no kid you
gave me no example Amy Lee
but I think I still say he's got some
Asian in him does he say anything about
his parents
uh I always watch it the next morning
like I record on Tuesday night because
nobody in my house wants to watch it so
I watch it at like 6 a.m on Wednesday
morning didn't get a chance to watch
this morning I assume Connor lost so
they're 0-8 now own seven yeah what's
tough is
then you guys know I'm such a big Conor
McGregor fan but you can tell he's just
kind of coasting and like whenever he
shows up shows up it's pushing a product
it's pushing his McGregor fast pushing
this his alcohol and that so you can
tell he's there just for because they're
paying him when Chandler's there for the
right reasons like he cares about
winning it's showing seems you know oh
and Congress teams Owen seven so I think
it's done more harm than good for Conor
he's not coming off as great his
Fighters aren't doing great he's the way
it could be the way they're editing it
he's not there a lot it's just it's just
it I mean it's kind of a black guy for
Connor when you're hoping to be a good
story and be rallying the troops and
it'd be competitive they [__] up I've
always said I've always oh and seven
I've always harped on this yeah they
said kind of set up for failure you're
taking young kids against vets of course
they're not winning you have to be such
an outlier to beat those vets man so
yeah the 0-7 so that he's kind of set up
for failure too I don't know if we're
talking about this if he was 7 know or
even if it was like four and three but
Owen seven the way they're editing he's
never there
it's it's yeah it's kind of boring
there's no really narratives on this
there's no characters on this season
it's a tough show man no pun intended
what's wrong with his legal issues I
haven't heard nothing shut up just pays
yes shut up oh you you gotta bring that
up with Connor what's going on with his
legal stuff is he gonna make it out of
it it's a real thing it's not though
what do you mean how many things has he
gotten that's a real that's a real life
yeah that's nothing it's not what do you
mean nothing he'll fight in December and
you know what nothing comes from it
nothing but nothing comes from it
because this [__] says that he did all
this stuff but we have video of her
hanging out with him afterwards right
afterwards oh they're they're gambling
together on the casino floor after what
this is a problem you don't pay
attention same way you do with politics
dude just read the headlines politics
yeah dude
you're annoying me right
you didn't know this though with Connor
I didn't know this part so you heard the
headline right you know well I just saw
I just saw the headline but that's
everyone you saw the headline and the
video in the video and I saw some
breakdowns of it but I didn't know that
stuff matters I didn't know she was yeah
no the the next day comes out she's
gambling with Connor right after the
fact I don't know if that's true you
wanna bet hold on don't bring it up 10
you want to bet
uh so I'm making this up bee
yeah you might be you might be a bubble
but that on it there's a thousand
dollars after this they saw her there's
been gambling with him yeah there's
video you know what's weird you think I
do this for a living hey Bet On It
because you don't know what the [__]
you're talking about yeah look that up
look that up
um Connor exposed excuse me I wish I had
taken this bet because I don't know
what's a better way to Google this Conor
gambling uh with accused uh Conor
gambling uh video with accuser
it's interesting because she's looking
for money not she didn't did she go to
the cops
um I don't know
so another one in the bathroom we know
the one in the bathroom
yeah buddy I think you made that up huh
I promise you I promise you she's just
really bad at Google
what you said look
film sat with rape accused just minutes
after she alleges it happened
in this video they're gambling together
seemingly sitting with a woman just
minutes after she cleaned the incident
took place
sat holding drinks with the woman who
claims that the U.S
uh it says engagement with his accused
before the nursery walks off
so I have to accuse him she's sitting
down having drinks with them they're
gambling no no hold on see this is where
you get a little bit you get a little
too excited the other problem with this
is the other problem with this this is
four weeks old fellas but you guys stop
saying that they were gambling you you
tend to take a lot of liberty no I'm
telling you it's just
uh okay there's videos them at clubs in
the casino there she is
[Music]
so I thought they were I thought they
were in the casino like at night at the
casino but they're in a club they're
sitting together so you're right they're
in the club they're not gambling but
they're sitting in a club it's weird
it's like I covered this four weeks ago
I'm just saying you know I'm saying like
that like but and this has been out
that's why you don't hear anything
anymore it's just all this video like
it's just and think about all things
he's been accused of
yeah we can go through it a lot a ton of
it
a ton of it doesn't touch him though
he's with her again that big arm next to
him that's our next one she's a big girl
big girl that's a big girl bro yeah yeah
that's his real loss though that's an
interesting thing
okay so well there you go so and then
she's looking for money you're a [__]
[__] but have you heard anything
about like that none of it that's why
I'm saying it was like I was like whoa
no
no no she went to her lawyer she didn't
go to the police she said hey tell him I
want money
yeah yeah I don't I don't know I think
she did file a police report but then
the police looked into it and then they
have the video for her hanging out with
him after it's all
[__] but he's been through worse
than this there's been worse
architecture in this and what happened
nothing
how many times do people accuse him of
rape you know he just has been nothing
yeah
the old man old man that was the
craziest one yeah the girl on the boat
said he did some like nothing but you
can't he's gonna fight in December
they're fighting December no the usada
is not involved if you're an actor and
that happens you're [__] if you're a
fighter you can there's something about
it if you're Conor if you're Connor yes
if you Leonardo DiCaprio you're fine if
you're Conor McGregor you're fine yeah
if you're Tom Hanks you're fine yeah if
you're Hunter biting you're fine yeah if
you're president United States Biden
you're fine yeah certain people are fine
and he was yeah and you never hear about
it no
yeah so Conor's gonna fight in December
guarantee it that I bet you the UFC's
announcement they're supposed to that's
what I was saying like what news that's
what made me think what news can you see
leak that's going to be bigger than Fury
versus Francis I'm going through
everything like again that's carnivorous
Chandler but that ain't gonna do it I
bet you that's the news we're gonna get
Connor Chandler December really yeah
they're gonna use the exemption for
Connor they're going to fight in
December
ah man
what else you got Jen
alrighty so Larry Nassar
that guy that sexually molested all
those Olympic athletes when they're kids
uh he was stabbed I think 10 times back
chest and neck but he still survived
Justice
I mean he still survived he's gonna be
in jail for the rest of his life but
yeah that's probably that's kind of cool
that he got how's he doing it will be
the last time either but then he also
got stabbed like down the hallway like
when he first entered prison they try to
get him so this general population
that's very surprising isn't that
awesome in the beginning Michigan is
that cool well well shout out to
Michigan State Prison good shout out
well wait I don't understand how he went
from that because in Tucson Arizona I
think they have they have criminals who
did sex crimes but they don't keep them
if you are especially if you're a chomo
yeah you get killed so how did they let
him in there I don't know who gives a
[__] yeah who gives a [__] he put him in
there yeah let him let him get assaulted
dude he's [__] he's [__] up yeah his
life's gonna be very tough don't molest
have you seen this video of this guy in
Vegas
it's a crazy story so this guy in Vegas
he first got it got in a fight with the
guy with no leg or no arm or something
like that then took off his clothes went
into a casino
and then started yelling so here it is
he had one leg he's got in a fight with
someone with one leg family came out and
said he was on drugs yeah he does he has
no recollection of any of this stuff
happens so here's the video and then he
started dancing on a Harrah's Casino
table that's him right there oh the
video is wild it's actually it looks
like he's a comedian
so he's like gyrating on top of the
table fully fully naked well
not good and you can see his dong right
there he's slapping that dick
this went on for a while it took a while
for the security to get him he's looking
for high fives security doesn't really
want to cry no that's the thing when
security is like a dude's naked don't
you guys have tasers foreign
[Music]
and at this point they put him in a
Chokehold I know they don't do that are
you allowed to put him in a choke I
don't know I don't think so but they
tackle them they got him here does he
get out of that oh they finally got him
they got him yeah
sir now is He Man from that suit from
that the guy was in an altered mental
state no [__] but Cooperative after his
arrest he's like I don't know what
happened man this is crazy he had was
obviously doing something bad he won't
serve any time no acid mushrooms
whatever it was and he uh it couldn't be
mushrooms though right it's gonna be a
lot crazy who knows some people say
schizophrenic and it could be
schizophrenic so you do not recall the
encounter I wonder for the next morning
he's like wait what'd I do well there
was a guy my parents my parents knew a
guy wait what happened it's yours I did
that
know a guy they know a guy who uh had to
had really bad diarrhea he asked to go
to the bathroom on the plane this the
flight attendant said you are not
getting up he got up and he shat
on top of the tray on top of it a shot
there yeah and uh he went to he didn't
go to jail but he got arrested it was a
big thing that guy should be in jail
opposed to this guy but yeah he just had
a moment again they're like dude you
were showing your starfish to everybody
like my [__] like yeah dude you put
your legs in the air like a baby you
know it's like and then showed one side
of the room then rotate showed the other
side he's like wow it's a legit defense
to say I don't remember because because
you can't prove it you're like I don't
so that's why when you get in an
accident some people run away well you
don't get convicted because they go he
might have his head he was disoriented
he ran away
um so you know in this case I don't know
that's obviously not normal behavior and
if you don't have a track record like
dude you did this at the [__]
Venetian you did this last week at the
Venetian nobody wants to do that when
they're sober I mean unless you're
you'll be a real wild boy you got him
here I mean I gotta dare
and his body's bad and [__] like you're
not gonna
just not good it's a bad body
sick dance moves though
little disgusting sick yeah huh no sick
dance moves so you remember that
Billionaire's stepson who went to a
Blink 182 concert where the submarine
was hit up all the only fan models yeah
he did he did even more now so
he's reading [__] now that's the guy I
think right right that's him just looks
awkward he tweeted that he can't get
laid even though he had that inheritance
so you see these sweets here
how much inheritance money did you get
anything more than zero is too much and
he goes more than you'll make in a
lifetime with all the cash I just want a
girl to hang out with please with
Millions to spare I still can't get laid
oh he's eating all this stuff right now
go get a girl dude you'll get a girl you
can take your money there are plenty of
professional and this was a great
this is a crazy one during the search
you respond to an only fans model
can I sit on you God he's uh he's uh
shooter shoot he's the stepson stepson
yeah he's the stepson he's uh
he's a little lost he said everyone who
has been kind to me um taken to Taylor
Swift's ears tour in La he's in by the
way yeah this guy needs friends so bad a
friend in the world poor guy this is not
the way to do it hit me up we're a
little guy no dude go back go back up
let me see the whole family there oh
that's them young though
so where's Mom
far left right that would be that's Mom
yes dude not that you don't know who
these people are for the aviation the
young girls a little bit more I don't
know my speed but it is what it is now
uh is he the kid yeah
when your parents die and you're talking
about trying to hook up with chicks like
clearly is an issue wait hold on go back
go back hi yo dude welcome back how's
the family holding up staying strong
thanks
okay praying for you family thank you
I'll be at the STS
I mean that's a Travis Barker I mean
it's his stepdad he clearly wasn't that
attached to his stepdad so
right I mean I guess not was it his
brother too well no no no I think it
sucks that's what it is at least he has
money
yeah go hang out with your money I guess
I don't know money can't buy you
happiness it's just that guy he's just
about a cool billionaires kid it's all
good he's like this hey guys what's
going on you know it's like he's good
guys who knows if he's a good girl we
don't know his tweets would beg to
differ yeah what's this you know what he
is he's awkward
you got this one Georgie let me guess
this is a dog catching fish which is
awesome yes it is and this is a dog
using bait to catch fish a piece of
cheese that's a bread loaf
I was just waiting for him to get to the
bread he would not eat the bread it's
bait he waited for the right moment
because one of his face
they come up and nibble on the bread
he grabbed one look at that look how
silly yep he's like oh yeah enjoy the
bread Fellers enjoy the bread
what if it was a 15 minute video of this
oh
oh oh
watch the Speed though the fish know
what's up they're like I don't know but
they're like you know what just get a
bite he's not gonna notice
that's cool ah dude what's down there is
there it's a 15 minute video of us just
yeah this is 16 the six days in these
side keep going I gotta I gotta roll
soon I get picked tiger up at noon 23
Minutes last one
this is a fish trying to escape a shark
uh you'll see the end of your dirty
exciting
oh he's trying to get away from that
shirt
a shark's [__] moving look at that
that's your life right there as a fish
yep you're always having a hard time
like don't eat fish it's like okay I'll
put them back in the wild yeah yeah it's
not dog eat dog it's fish eat fish so
then the bird got it yeah
so when one out of a thousand Turtles
when they hatch make it okay they gotta
do the crawl in the trash just jump on
them Birds oh [__] one guy's like
man that was Crick the [__] is it right
the hell got eaten dude Blue Room I'll
see you July 20th 21st I'm sorry July
21st 22nd Blue Room in Springfield
Missouri Ontario Improv July 28 29 cap
cities August three four and five my
very special guest May show up
may show up he's big he's thick that's
all I'm gonna tell you that's the only
hint you get oh we added a few we got
shopping friends Pasadena July 28th uh
one night Omaha Nebraska what is that an
improv out there
yeah
uh I think it's CM Prof
there I said it I like that club I like
that club and I like Oma stay in the old
uh the old Marketplace yeah that helps
Farmers um so shopping friends Pasadena
that's July 28th one show only Omaha
Nebraska Cornhuskers come on out August
16th that's just added Kansas City
Missouri August 17th Liberty Township
Ohio's August 30th Columbus Ohio August
31st then I'm in Spokane skank Fest and
New York November 4th through the 5th
all right kids those new dates just got
added go get them love you guys tickets
at thickboy.com that's it
love you